the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
gonna say look I've got two thousand one
out of seven two thousand one is my
dividend that's the thing I'm sharing
out to lots of people and seven is the
divisor that's how many comes I'm just
blown up into okay so what's the first
question I asked of 2001 f7 what I do
this yes very good
so I'm gonna go through each one of
these numbers and think about how many
times I can fit it in there how many
times do I fit seven leads or two it's
up zero and if you remember when we were
doing the diagnostic right it's really
important you're right serious down
don't just forget about like oh it
doesn't matter because there are none
zero groovy matters as a number as you
can see this is two thousand 1.21 so
having written down zero company
something's in there how many sevens can
I fit in 2020 yeah I can fit two because
I go seven fourteen the next one's 21
which is too big okay so now what do I
do
at this point now keep in mind by the
way I'm trying to do this through long
division and I'm trying to do less in my
head if I can't yes okay so I've got 20
take away 2 times 7 that's where the 14
comes from right so I'm gonna write that
14 down there do you remember this will
go through the whole division okay and I
do the subtraction that ADA was
suggesting so 20 take away 14 of course
is 6 fantastic okay now I can't fit any
7s in there which is the whole point of
saying this number so I need to go to
the next number so some of you you might
like to draw that arrow down like that
because cut for any in six
I'll bring the next number down which
happens to also be a zero okay there's a
bit of a big number
how many sevens can we video somebody
hasn't said anything just yet someone
offer yes Maria 8 ok let's try eight let
me just see if I get it right so 7 do we
send together 7 14 21 28 35 42 49 50
it fits what's the next one the next one
be 63 which is too far okay so Maria got
a new one
so I want to write down eight up here
and eight times seven like we just said
is 56 why am I writing it down your
input what's the point of doing that
yeah yeah so I could do the 60 take away
56 I know a lot of people are gonna do
the little numbers up here and it's kind
of okay but I'm trying to avoid doing
things up in my head like this
subtraction if I write it down that way
I can know that it's gonna be right if I
get it wrong I can work out where it
went wrong rather than like a whole
bunch of the remember I'm not sure maybe
60 take away 50 60 years is good and of
course I can't fit any sevens in there
so I bring down the last come up which
is of what we just went through on our
fingers we just rehearse all there's
multiple so how many multiples are
something's not getting 41 and the
answer is okay now I've kind of run out
of in space I'm gonna move this a bit
further down okay now I will get to the
remainder in a second that's my very
last step so I've got 35 down key 5/7
and now I'm going to do the subtraction
right last 121 take my 35 yes six and
there are no more numbers to pulled out
with errors so that's my remainder you
happy with that
yeah okay now because I rubbed it off
can someone repeat to me what was the UM
what was 11 divided by what was it 3 5
to 4 is that right 3 5 4 2 did I stop
them around okay so this time rather
than talking through it in so much
detail because I think now we've sort of
got in our head I'll do this one a bit
quicker and you can check your answer
and also the way you set it down please
if you didn't write it down like this to
show the long division please copy down
I'll leave it on the board for a second
when I'm working through your book part
I'm not just looking I've said
not just looking for that final number
285 m806 is important but I want to see
the journey they've got a bit of logic
that you demonstrated John I'm mainly
going to focus on these okay because
this way it's like yeah I'm explicitly
sort of mentioning I'm expecting a
really nice tan in that you've marked
and corrected your work and so on I may
have a peek through the rest a book but
these are the main things I'm gonna be
painted okay we'll do this one quicker
this time I don't for any 11s in the
first number I fit 311 s in the next one
okay
so that's how this comes down and I
subtract so far so good I bring down the
floor and now I can fit in to eleven
right which gives me 22 and then I
subtract last one to bring out the two
between two again I fit to it and what's
the remainder there's no race did I get
it right look okay breathe hey by the
way that's a bit of coincidence I just
maybe have been up is on the spot so I
got lucky that I got a multiple of 11
yes yes I went I would run those off or
others up I would just leave those there
I suppose I should have right at the end
that's where the remainder comes out
okay